hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
checking out a trailer today two
trailers one is for a sonic boom rise of
lyric and the other one is sonic boom
shattered crystal now I'm really
interested in this Sonic the Hedgehog
series there's these particular video
games because I heard they're coming out
with like a television show and these
are supposed to serve as like the
prequels to that show so that's pretty
cool like if you want to get the prequel
experience you have to go and play these
games which i think is [ __ ] awesome
and I hear like everyone's back I hear
tails is back I hear knuckles is back
and here they got a cool new character
twigs something like that sticks sticks
it sticks and I think it's really cool
because each of these characters is
gonna have their own like unique
abilities like Sonic has a speed and
it's cool attacks tails has like gadgets
and [ __ ] and pig tails can fly knuckles
can like go underground and climb well
you guys all know this [ __ ] already hey
you can switch back and forth between
the characters too like you can actually
just keep going she'll wanna be tails or
someone would be song at this time like
that that's really cool you know because
it's not like they're all just Sonic the
Hedgehog just look different you know
they're not like in it right you so with
this it this is really unique to me I'm
just excited because it sounds like this
sonic games gonna have like a storyline
to it that will be a lot of fun so I
believe the first one is called rise of
lyric let's check it out for Sega
Genesis Sonic may not seem like it
land is home to an agent
no not him but even older a devious
force imprisoned below the surface for
more than 1,000 years waiting for its
chance at revenge
you and I have unfinished business I
have no idea what you're talking about
but I'm pretty sure it's a bad thing
Wow what I forgot out so sonic was just
small but evil alliance used to assemble
extraordinary
now pulse is like weightlifting
for a wonder ground
like taking all robots move it
that looks like so much I just love
Sonic because you know it's got like
that out of that old-school flavor to it
like what the Mario games have you know
just like nostalgia feeling to it just
how it's like colorful and stuff but
cartoony and that's like you know how
old-school video games were now
everything's like cinematic and dark and
this is just like good old-fashioned fun
now I don't really know the difference
between the two games [ __ ] it let's find
out
like from the side view
it's so buff now
Thanks
our
well yeah I mean I wanted to check out
these trailers because I love the whole
concept behind a prequel it looks like
it's gonna deliver I'm excited to play
these games just what makes onyx so cool
this is sounds so stupid and obvious
what makes them so cool is how [ __ ]
fast he can go because what other game
character can you really just go like
there should be a 3d IMAX movie with
like animation about sonic boom sonic I
mean the Hedgehog that would be [ __ ]
perfect man I would totally check that
[ __ ] out because it's right there from
the Aminah I hope the show is good but
hopefully if the show is good enough
they like adapt it into a [ __ ]
awesome film because you could do like
cool ass [ __ ] with Sonic Man how [ __ ]
cool is Sonic oh you just roll super
fast and run super fast that's just
Sonic is the best man so I was the best
fast people are cool
trust me I'm fast I can do everything
fast girl you give me you'll Aegina give
you the best ten seconds of your life I
want to get some shoutouts here Marga
Robinson said Ryan you're hilarious
I know love your videos please give me a
shoutout well Marta you probably have a
vagina Marta sounds like a girl's name
so this is my seduction voice I would
like to make love to you on an ocean but
your hair is is soft as a baby's bottom
in your teeth or is yellow is my urine I
don't know what the [ __ ] kind of shadow
this is I'm trying to hit on you but I
keep coming over the stupidest stuff
Rocco Sanel he's I wondering like where
his shoutouts man well guess what a
Rocco your shoutouts here my friend this
guy has his own YouTube channel I know
this I have checked it out before does
reviews and [ __ ] check out his channel
it's good he's like 10 years old or
something
it's cute adorable my friend keep it up
get some contacts someday your glasses
look good now get some contacts you're
gonna be one sexy [ __ ] and I'm
telling you my 10 year old friend you
will get a lot of prune anyone
just keep it up keep up the knowledge
maybe start working out now that way you
can be buffed by the time you're like in
high school and playing on the football
team get a lot of cheerleading [ __ ]
it's gonna be awesome
Brian Brennan he's been worrying where
his shout-out is to well I guess you
said I am the man you're the man you're
the best kind of man there is a little
man you're also pretty young I feel like
the demographic of this channels
audience is like 10 to 12 year old for
something like that yeah good for you
thanks for watching the channel I hope
that I inspire you to be more crude more
vulgar a little bit disrespectful to
people to hit on women non-stop I hope
that by the time your balls drop you
will know what to do after all the
masturbation tips I've given on this
channel